all right diamond
hello hi diamond uh where where'd you
grow up diamond
um i grew up like in between like um
like 30th 34th street in king
and um i also like stayed in like the
vermont news area
okay so now you're in south central yes
i'm you're back in the vermont loser
yeah
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents um no my dad
he was incarcerated for eight years he
went to jail when i was eight years old
and um he got out when i was 16.
well as a kid i think like i was the
youngest child
and and um i was very active i think i'm
my mom's problem child
a lot of people sound different and you
know so as a kid i was growing up
i was i went to a residential home in
utah
i was put away because like i was like
12 11 i started running the streets
i started like game banking hanging out
doing drugs
and i started surrounding myself with
people that
didn't really didn't have my best
interest and then i
i i just developed like a lifestyle
something a habit
and it's just something that i've just
been doing ever since what age did this
start
um i mean like when it comes to me
acting out and stuff you know
i was always put away i probably was
like eight acting out but like when i
started running away i was like
10 11. and you started working the
streets at what age
um eleven eleven yeah i was always lying
about my age everywhere i went
i went to jail my cousin one time and he
was like dang you know now that i think
about it you've been
18 for three years now you know
but so yeah so you were working as a
prostitute on figaro yes yes yes
not at 11 that's the first time i turned
my date first time you turned the date
was yes
at what age um because i stayed like on
51st and 5th so you know on my way to
school
i went to 51st on my way to school i
i was walking down the runway and this
truck driver i was like
12 maybe 11. 11 or 12. yes
so that's like what grade that's
probably six seven
six grades wow do you remember that
first time
yes what was it was that the first time
you had sex
no it wasn't no no no no no
i didn't i didn't um i wasn't really
having sex
then but i had did a sexual favor for
the man oh i see okay
was there any abuse or anything like
that in your childhood when you were
younger
um yes i was touched by a cousin of mine
and i never really told because like
i was made out to be the promiscuous one
or you know i never really said anything
and then like i didn't put myself in
situations where i would run
i was very vulnerable to men and i felt
like
like it's rape you know it's rape when
you don't want to have to do something
but somebody
making you feel like it because you're
uncomfortable i've been put in a lot of
those situations you know
are you working in the pimp at that age
um
um i no i met this guy
um when i was 15 years old and i started
dating with him or whatever and he was
the pimp but
he was also selling drugs too but he
ended up dying
have you been arrested for this before
no never been arrested
no no have you been roughed up and had
bad experiences with some of the
customers
yes i have i've been cheated and it
[ __ ] sucks
that's why i don't like like working the
streets i really work through it
yeah so you do it through calls yeah
stuff like that
[Music]
do you still encounter guys that are
problems your trouble
i mean not so much like of theirs just
you more have to watch out for the feds
you know oh so it's almost the same game
just
you're doing it online instead of on the
street yes
do you have kids of your own no how old
are you 25
you're 25.
your dad was in prison for what um
he had i don't remember using i was i
was eight years old
but i think it was like robbery but you
know he already was like
um he already been to jail before but
they just held him this long time
because he violated his probation he
went for nine years he got out
march 5th march 4th 2009
and i got out march 5th 2009 and i came
from my residential home
um in utah and um
ever since then i i've just been running
the streets
like you know it's just become a way to
i don't see myself doing nothing else
sometimes did you finish high school
almost how much money do you make in a
night
during the day it depends like because
you know i spend it as i go
you know yeah so it depends like i'll be
touching like
man i'll be touching like on a snow day
like
maybe like 600 700 on a good day maybe
it depends it varies it really varies
does your family know you do this i try
not to tell them but i know they have a
good idea
does it get you down sometimes you get
depressed sometimes
yes yes yes yes because i just
i just be wanting to have someone you
know to talk to but
i'm fine to get along with the voices in
my head now because
um like it's hard to explain somebody
your lifestyle or like
what you think or i don't know like just
what i be going through it's hard to
explain that to somebody and not get the
not saying i want to hear a certain
answer but it's always like criticism
coming along you know
i don't i don't know i don't know like i
don't know how to explain it
but i'm not trying to have my pity party
for myself but
people don't know until they really come
here you know like you just get treated
different
i like your cigarettes
thank you what's the hardest part of
of doing this for a living
once you start you can't stop and
no matter how you um
no matter how you try to play it out you
always come across something it's like
it's like a
a a not like it's like it's like a
sin on you or something wherever you go
like it's just gonna always follow you
like an addiction yes
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about
that other people don't quite understand
what what goes on for you guys
um well because a lot of
when it comes from the women
stereotypically
me you know i'm the scale um
i'll say is because there is probably
their men that be paying for it and they
they like to like make that down because
the way we dress or you know
it's but you know that's the business
that's what sells
you know so i think people
i mean it's if it was easy to get a job
this is
easy just to walk to the corner and
catch a date i would have one i would
have
three yeah
it's it's hard like it's like
least you're not at this point you know
at least you found
because once you like get in it's hard
to get out because it's something that
you become accustomed to
[Music]
you been in love before
i'm only 25. i have
why you asked no i just wonder if this
lifestyle kind of makes it difficult
for my love life yeah oh that's crazy
you said that
yes everything it must be right yes if
you and i were dating
yes and you were seeing five guys at
tonight yes it would be difficult for me
yes
yes yes yes and for you yes
yes
you think you're happy am i happy are
you a happy person
i'm a happy person yes i have i have yes
i'm a happy person i don't try to be
miserable but
like happy like i see stuff and i be
feeling bad a lot
but happy i'm a happy person
i'm not miserable i'll be happy with
myself
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking about doing
something like what you do
um um
always try to keep something going for
yourself always at the end of the day
have your best interest
and and everything to the eye that's
intriguing is not
to to your to your lifestyle like don't
be
don't don't be so quick to um to um
try to be in just and and i mean
really just find morals and what is
really like
like i don't know how to explain it just
find the morals of things the values of
things
or you know but just always try to keep
something going try to invent something
try to come up with something the newest
something
or you know try to stay ahead like that
like
the other stuff is like really like
i don't know it'd be cool for them but
as as you go
and the the men you know like i don't
know just
i would i would really if i could start
all over again i would be slow
into talking to men and slow into
believing men
and um i kind of would change the crowd
of me
do you think doing this be particular
about who you surround yourself with
because at the end of the day that's who
you become you think
doing this all these years has changed
the way you view men
yes because the guys you're meeting over
and over again or yes
or probably a different yeah because
[Music]
it may be like it's to where it's hard
to um
like it's just my certain way that i am
that in my relationship my god he
doesn't like it he says and i know he's
not lying because
it's true like why would you say some
stuff like that you know i don't try to
let him know my business on that
but i don't lie about it but i don't try
to like be brief with him about it but
that's the problem in the back of his
head i know it is
how do you think doing this since you
were a young teenager has changed you
man i um
it's all you've ever done i i i just
that's what i it's like a job of mine so
i just do it that's how i survive and
in order to do it i gotta run the
streets and sometimes in order to run
the streets i have to do drugs you know
are drugs part of the picture for you um
it can be at times i like marijuana and
pills
all right darling thank you so much for
talking with me
and good luck with the rest of your life
you're still young
yes i am
you